with the passing of queen elizabeth ii
i would like to look a little bit about
the
legacy that she has left behind to look
a little bit at
the symbolism of monarchy itself
and maybe
have a few thoughts on the new king our
new king as a canadian prince charles
iii
some things that the people in the
symbolic world us a few thoughts that
hopefully will
will be things that we need to pay
attention to in the next few years
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so whether or not you agree with the
notion of monarchy or constitutional
monarchy i think that most people agree
that
the queen elizabeth ii was a
very impressive person
she
had a
very impressive demeanor the way that
she was able to engage with people
all through her life the manner in which
you know
different from her own children was
capable to of avoiding scandal
and in her own life as well and i think
that for many people she will
be missed
and so
right now we a lot of people are talking
about the transition whether or not this
will be an opportunity here in canada
especially you hear people saying
whether or not this is an opportunity to
to question the monarchy to question the
institution
if it would be a good time for canadians
to get rid of
the constitutional monarchy as the
source of our government
and
i want to talk a little bit about
some of the symbolism of monarchy
let's say some of the negative aspects
and some of the positive aspects that
you find
in scripture but also in the history
in scripture monarchy is presented
actually in a double way on the one hand
in the book of samuel it is presented as
something which at the outset would be
negative that the people are clamoring
for a king instead of worshiping god or
instead of depending on god so it's as
if they want to put a king in place of
god
and because of that samuel warns them
that the king will
take their children you know will will
take the best of them
to fight in their wars and as and and
their daughters as wives and so there's
ascension in that that the king can
become
place of attention which could take away
from the attention that we need to put
on god because it's a kind of it's a
place where all the attention
meets at the top
but there is also another testimony in
scripture about the king which is that
in the book of judges you have all these
prophets that come but the prophets come
and go and there are these cycles of
prophets and the prophets come and then
something happens the prophets go and
then things turn into chaos or sometimes
the prophets bring about a kind of chaos
or a kind of
of confusion uh because of both because
of people making promises that they
can't keep and so there's a sense in
which the in the book of judges the
stories that you have they're very much
related to the difficulty of heaven and
earth connecting together and how
they they tend to disconnect
especially in the idea of making a
promise which is untenable you know you
have that story that is really similar
to the story of beauty and the beast
where you know a father promises to
sacrifice his daughter and then it's
like this crazy thing that that he does
that this crazy promise that he that he
makes and so there's a many images of
that of course the story of samson is
also about the difficulty of joining
heaven and earth represented in many
extreme images
um and so and then it says in the book
of judges constantly like there was not
yet a king in israel as if now the king
can also be seen as a hook or an anchor
which can join heaven and earth together
properly if this is the if it's done
right
and so in
so you could see say that you could also
see in in general as something like
how
god transforms the fallen institutions
and the fallen structures into something
which can also function for his glory so
although samuel says like you you know
the reasons why you want a king are the
wrong ones and that a king will be
dangerous to you nonetheless the king
king david and king solomon
are the ones who build the temple and
the temple becomes an image you know of
a further image going moving towards the
new jerusalem the heavenly jerusalem
which which comes to the end of
scripture and in christianity we also
have a sense in which the king is a
possibility a place where heaven and
earth can hook together if the king is
submitted to god if the king receives
his crown from the bishop if the crow if
the king submits his worldly authority
to a higher spiritual power
but
even in even in christianity there's
always a danger which is that
by giving so much power and authority to
one person there is of course the danger
that that can be misused and that they
can take it for themselves become
prideful and then act
in their own name rather than acting
under the will of god the crown that
they've received from above you could
say that they have to receive the crown
from above there's a tendency to want to
take that crown for ourselves but the
image of the king is nonetheless an
image which is used without any apology
in scripture to speak about
a way to understand the role that god
has in the world and also a way to
understand christ
one of the aspects of christ is to
understand him as a king as an emperor
and there are many images in the
tradition
which use that that image and so the
king just like any worldly manifestation
is a
is a position is an image that is can be
ambiguous or they can have two sides if
those sides
if
if the position is not oriented properly
is probably the best way to understand
it
but
one of the things that the king and the
royalty can do is act as a visible
point above multiplicity which is able
to gather attention and is able to make
us recognize that we participate that we
are one that we are together that we
share an identity and so we could see
that the for example the the crown in
the uk
has acted that way very much and you see
it also not just in the uk but in other
countries that still have that still
have royalty that when there's
multiplicity within the people so if in
the the uk you know you have ireland you
have
you have scotland and then you have
the the
you have england but you also have
whales and so you have all these
cultures that that exist and have a very
long and fraught history
together
but they are all able to recognize in
the
in the royal family something which is
not bound in all these small
provincial conflicts
often that happens through the royalty
actually being adjoining of the
different tribes right so when we talk
about you know the idea of marriage
alliances as joining
uh people together we sometimes think
that it's strange and superstitious and
that this is like why is it that you
know some king marrying some princess
from some land is going to join people
together like why is that happening well
it is because their children will not
have only one identity their children
will have an identity that is joined
together
and contains more more identity together
and so that will reflect itself not just
in their
their biological you know dna or
whatever but will manifest itself in
also their allegiance and their
attention that is their attention will
be something like a joining of two
possible allegiances into one and so the
children of the union
will transcend the multiplicity that is
down below and so that is of course the
ideal it doesn't always happen that way
they're obviously like in every human
system there are times where it goes
goes astray and that doesn't that it
doesn't do that but you can understand
at least the principle of why something
like that would be useful to have uh so
you could um imagine like the difference
between mixture so all these royal
families in europe were all non-national
to a certain extent because they were
all marrying amongst each other and they
were like they were like a transnational
place transnational
uh people but that also had allegiance
to their nation that is the king is is
beyond the squabbles that can happen
between the the
between the
between england and wales let's say
between the different the different
cultures um but that he is responsible
for those squabbles and so therefore is
engaged let's say from above
to trying to reconcile them and trying
to bring those those differences
together so that is obviously a role
that the
that the king has played in history
and that still plays i think i think
that the british crown still actually
plays that role today
and joins together in a kind of
allegiance
all the english-speaking nations uh you
know
that that have their history in
their connection to the crown um so that
is something that
can help us understand it and also it
can help us understand why often
these royal in the modern world
especially a lot of these royal
characters have played more
ritual roles that they have ritual
a function rather than a direct state
function and we tend to think that
sometimes that's useless what's the
point why do we have put all this money
into
having this these people or this person
at the top that actually isn't
making the laws that isn't involved in
the in the laws
but it is
it becomes ritual because it is in a way
a manner to bind our attention and to
bind our allegiance and to bind all
these things together towards a person
and that happens like in church it
happens in processions it happens in
parades it happens in
in you know in
the uh the ceremonial person at the top
giving honor to other people knighting
people doing all this kind of stuff
which which seems like a
it seems can seem to some people at
least like just superstitious nonsense
but is
a manner in which they bind the the
nation together and give a direction and
give quality to what it means to be
you'd say in the british commonwealth
something like that um and this is
something which
for example the the ceremonial aspect of
a ruler is something which has happened
many times in history before
in the in the byzantine empire in the
byzantine state let's say
it was customary or it's something that
happened quite a few times where there
was a separation between the ritual
aspect of the emperor and the
legislative or more state-related aspect
of the emperor sometimes that would be
separated into two people so there would
be kind of co
there would be co-emperors one who would
be in constantinople and would
would participate in the church services
the liturgies the processions all these
all that what we could call pageantry
but which was there
to to participate in the identity of
byzantium and to to gather people into
that identity and then there was someone
else who was more kind of the practical
emperor who was involved in deciding
where to go to war and you know to deal
with all that that kind of stuff um and
so it's not something so when we see
that the british crown has become almost
only ceremonial
i think that we have to think that we
don't necessarily have to think that
that is only bad that it that it
actually has a function
which is not just purely economic or
purely it is a function that has to do
with identity itself now
as we come to this transition and we
move towards prince
king charles iii you know there's a lot
of people a lot of people have many
criticisms to offer to the royal family
and
to the children of the the queen
but there are a few things to think
about in terms of this king charles who
is who is attaining the throne right now
of course he does have scandals in his
life you know he the whole story with
princess deanna and then his
is cheating on her and
his other relationship all this stuff um
there is of course that there is there
are some people also that find that he
lacks the kind of
backbone and the kind of presence that
would be needed
to replace someone like queen elizabeth
ii
but there are also other things to think
about now in terms of this symbolic
world people
uh
there is it's interesting to remember
for example that prince philip his
father
was born
greek orthodox
and became anglican later in order to
marry
the queen
but also
kept a relationship with the orthodox
world and that relationship seems to
have been passed down to his son
and so
king charles has a
has a very profound relationships with a
profound relationship with some of the
elders on mount athos and
and gets advice and travels there
maybe he won't do it so more but used to
travel there quite a bit in order to
engage with
the monks at mount athos and so he has a
deep sympathy for that that is that is
also where he met for example the
iconographer aidan hart when they were
both in athos
and
at the same time king charles has a
sympathy for
traditionalists or perennialist authors
he there's a video going around that
people have been passing around uh and
being surprised you know this is
something that i've known for a very
long time but i but i understand why
some people are surprised to realize
that he uh that he has been a
supporter financial and just in terms of
of giving his approval to many of the
perennialist
efforts
the journals the conferences
and also he started a school in london
called the prince's school of
traditional arts which is trying to
restore the traditional vision of art
aiden hart is a professor there
and the school is run though is run by
sufis
and so this is also
where on the one hand there is a
positive aspect to his relationship to
perennialism that is that he does seem
to at least care about the notion that
there are principles manifest that are
manifesting in the world that there are
eternal
patterns and eternal
let's say realities that infuse
the the world of manifestation and that
hold it together that traditional
religions are part of that all of that
seems to be
to be the case but at the same time
there is a danger in perennialism which
i've mentioned and i think that we can
actually see the danger of perennialism
in this case which is that
there's a danger in that perennialism
actually does the opposite of what the
the first authors of that group wanted
which is that the first authors of the
group wanted
something like to show the
transcendental transcendent principles
behind the different religions but that
you also should embody one particular
path and that you should be engaged
in one one particular path but
when you talk like that in public and
when you you have put those ideas out
like that in writing
there's a manner in which people will
start to act as if they are beyond the
the traditions they'll start to compare
religions and they'll have all these
journals and things of comparative
religion that will take up more and more
space and at some point they will start
to act as if they themselves are above
religion and that they can look at all
these religions and kind of compare them
and judge them and see what's good in
all of them um and so
that leads to something like globalism
and a kind of relativism
and i think that that seems at the same
time although
it's very fascinating to see how it
seems like that the king charles's
perennialism seems to
at least to a certain extent have led
him
into the arms of the world economic
forum and to these kind of global
agendas and this kind of global soup
that seems to be manifesting itself like
this this
this kind of global moving towards
something like a world government or
something like that uh
he seems to have been on board now i
don't know to what extent he is to what
extent he is just superficial
in his allegiance to these things this
is something that we will see in the
next few years
but i think it is definitely something
that we should be paying attention to
and watching
and and seeing
being able to recognize whatever good
comes out of his
of his kingship
and also be attentive and be able to
recognize what is what is dangerous and
what moves towards the kind of
post-modern slosh you know whatever
that is setting
itself up and so um and so uh at the end
of this all i can say is indeed the
queen is dead god saved the king
and uh maybe he were may he be worthy
of that title